FELIPE HOFFA: My
name is Felipe Hoffa.
You are interested
in visualizing data.
Prepare to rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
For years, I've used
BigQuery and public data
sets to publish
interesting articles.
And I've used many different
visualization tools.
But there was still
a space in my life
until Data Studio showed up.
Google Data Studio is totally
free for you and for me.
And I can use it to publish
interactive visualizations
online.
And it's really easy to connect
it to many different sources,
including BigQuery.
So that's what I did.
I analyzed data with BigQuery.
I connected it to Data Studio.
I made my dashboards
interactive.
And I published them online.
You can embed a Data
Studio dashboard anywhere,
including some of the most
popular plugin platforms.
But there are some challenges.
As you know, BigQuery allows
you to analyze huge amounts
of data in very few seconds.
And it only charge to you
for each query you run.
And it has a free monthly tier.
So you might end up
paying nothing at all.
But if you connect BigQuery
to a popular dashboard,
then your users may
end up generating a lot
of queries on your behalf.
And that means you can end
up with a huge BigQuery bill.
We don't want that.
So I asked the
developer advocate
for Data Studio, Minhaz
Kazi, to join me on state
to share our best strategies for
publishing dashboards with Data
Studio and BigQuery.
For example, the
easiest way to avoid
pushing new queries from
Data Studio to BigQuery
is to materialize the results of
your queries into Data Studio.
That's right, once you
have the BigQuery results
or table you want
to visualize, you
can use the Extract
button to do so.
And Data Studio will offer you
an easy way to keep and refresh
a copy of this data.
But right now, that feature
is still in development.
And it will be subject
to certain limitations.
So we also shared
some other options
to create an inexpensive
layer between Data Studio
and BigQuery.
For example, you can
use G Suite Apps Script
to schedule queries and have the
results pushed to Google Cloud
Storage.
You can then connect Data
Studio to that file, which
will be refreshed
based on your schedule.
And your users will be able to
quickly explore the results.
But this works only up to
a certain size of results.
In other cases, it may
make a lot of sense
to use a database that
supports lookup by key.
Once you know that your
visualization will all
require key lookups
to retrieve data,
instead of scanning
a table in BigQuery,
you can connect Data Studio
to a traditional database
and just get the
individual rows out of it.
In this case, I exported
the BigQuery results
to a MySQL database
hosted on Cloud SQL.
I added the required indexes.
And we got quick,
inexpensive results.
But sometimes you might
have more complex needs--
for example, when you
want to make a data
source available to
many users and let them
build their own
customized visualizations.
In that case, you can
create a Data Studio custom
connector with Apps Script and
design your own caching logic
within it.
In the full talk, you
can see this in action
with Minhaz's example, where he
created a connector that anyone
can use with just
a couple clicks.
And they get a custom and
customizable visualization
with fresh data,
hosted in BigQuery,
without any need of
coding, SQL or otherwise.
In summary., if you want to
connect BigQuery and Data
Studio to create an
interactive dashboard,
and you want to
make this dashboard
available for everyone,
remember to think
about what kind of layer you
want to have between BigQuery
and Data Studio.
And stay tuned.
Because at Google, we
are always thinking
about how to make this
connection even more powerful.
If you'd like to
see the full talk,
check out the link in
the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Google Cloud Platform
YouTube channel for more
great Next Rewind content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]